يا
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحم الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
يقول الحافظ النووي رحمه الله وعن ام
المؤمن
صفيه بنت حيي رضي الله عنها صفيه بنت حيت
صلى الله عليه وسلم
تقول كان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم معتكفا
فاتيته ازوره ليلا فحدثته ثم قنت ثم قمت
لانقلب
فقام معي
ليقلبني ليقلبني يعني يروحني على البيت في
الليل
فمر رجلان من الانصار رضي الله عنهما فلما
راي النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اسرعا
جمعهم الطريق
راوا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
مع امراته
لم يعرفوها اسرع المشي
صلى الله عليه وسلم
after
me
home and as
home
فقال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم على رسلكما
على رسلك يعني شويه على رسلك يعني تبطا خذ
راحتك شويه على رسلكما للتثنيه هنا يعني
اثنين يخاطب اثنين انها صفيه بنت حيي يعني
التي معي ولم يقل هذه صفيه بنت حيي لماذا؟
هذا من ادب العرب الرفيع لا يريد ان يجلب
الانتباه الى زوجه
فيقول انها فيحدث عنها بضمير الغائب بدل
ما يقول هذه يجلب الانظار الى زوجه
هذا
المستمع ينظر الى من تتكلم عنه ولكن قال
انها فيحدث عنها بضمير الغائب من ادب ال
العرب واللغه العربيه الرفيعه جدا
وهذه من اداب النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ومن غيرته على عرضه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صفيه بنت حي
would
[Silence]
فقال سبحان الله يا رسول الله
يعني ما ظننا فيك من سوء وما ظننا شرا
سبحان الله او
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان الشيطان يجري من ابن ادم مجرى الدم
واني خشيت ان يقذف في قلوبكما شرا او قال
شيئا ان يقذف في قلوبكما شرا او ان يقذف
في قلوبكما شيئا
said سبحان الله
being
‏prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
الله اعلم
un other
un
‏And so
I
this so because I feared that would
whisper some evil to you mean that this
is
situation where you see the propeting
and he got with him this woman
‏is
some other
night
soable sitation
الله وسلم على نبينا
كلام
الله
وعليكم
السلام عليكم وبركاته كيف